un día ajetreado para estos activistas
de italianos del partido de extrema
derecha hermanos de Italia su objetivo
convencer a los descontentos del
movimiento 5 estrellas que había
obtenido casi al 50% de los votos en
sicilia durante las últimas elecciones
legislativas Hace cuatro años
he votado por cinco estrellas en su
momento parecía en el partido de la
renovación con nuevas ideas pero desde
que están en el poder me han
decepcionado
[Música]
es el alcalde de este pueblo al oeste de
Palermo elegido Gracias al apoyo del
partido democrático de Centro izquierda
el también ha dado la espalda hoy hace
campaña por el partido de Georgia meloni
y comparte su enfoque soberanista
es una persona dicisa es una persona
decidida hay que cambiar a Europa porque
hay muchas cosas que no funcionan
necesitamos Un gobierno fuerte que
proteja los intereses de los italianos
por encima de todo prima y el interés
italiano sicilia es una de las regiones
más afectadas por la crisis energética
que azota el país
aquí el paro supera el 20% y una cuarta
parte de la población vive por debajo
del umbral de la pobreza Antonio lleva
10 años trabajando en este bar casado y
con dos hijos lucha por mantener a su
familia con un único salario
difícilmente con la subida de los
precios cada vez es más difícil mantener
una familia de forma digna Espero que el
nuevo gobierno me permita hacer frente a
los gastos diarios de mi familia
electricidad agua gas alquiler
una esperanza que comparte con Roberto
uno de los comerciantes de la zona
considera que los hermanos de Italia es
el único partido capaz de ayudarle a
hacer frente a la inflación galopante
melonida respuestas concretas Espero que
esta vez se reduzcan los impuestos
porque para nosotros los impuestos se
han convertido en un verdadero problema
Cuando tenemos una actividad comercial
aquí lo podemos pagarles más
apagarla si los hermanos de Italia
mantienen su avance y superan a los
demás partidos de derecha de Italia el
país podría haber por primera vez en su
historia a una mujer de ultraderecha al
frente de su gobierno